hello everyone sorry about no video
yesterday I was really busy brushing up
on the whole negotiation saga between
Alaska and capablanca those guys were
really insane and well you'll just have
to wait and see the negotiations before
the match are are just as important as
the match itself it's really a lot of a
lot of pages of negotiations this guy
sends letter to this guy then this guy
sends letter to this guy then two other
guys get included in the gun
negotiations and then they start sending
letters it's really crazy and well it's
it will take me some time to make sense
of everything but until I make that
video ready and I do hope to make it
ready today we do return to this Leela
onslaught that goes on in the in the
season 14 of the TCC the top chess
engine competition we already mentioned
two days ago that Leela has won the Cup
and now
Leela faces the mighty stockfish in a
100 game match and it's a it's a
different version of stuff which a
stronger version of stockfish and they
are they will be playing in these 100
games well they will be using an opening
book but they will be using openings
with very aggressive wine so one line
that one would not choose I fit well
weren't forced to play it such as this
game in this game was recommended by you
guys a lot of you have recommended it
and it's really a nice game where a
stock first goes for the French defense
and well you just have to wait and see
but yeah as usual the link will be in
the description below you can follow the
live match it's a 100 game match they
are only I believe at the game 25
currently or maybe 24 but yeah feel free
to follow the match so let's get to the
game Lila has the white pieces and we
have E 4 e 6 like we mentioned that the
French defense is on the board and now
Knights the D to the tower variation of
the French knight c6 we have Knight G to
f3 Knight to f6 and now comes a 5
forcing the knight back
we have 937 and now comes the Knight to
b3
this is still a part of the opening they
are forced to play we have B 6 and now C
3 and this position has only been
reached once in over the board human
clay and I have prepared this for you so
you can check it out it was played in
2001 in her cunny between johan Haas and
ulamahs Aras and in this game as you can
see here it's again between players
rated 2068 and 2349 the game ended in a
draw so not a popular line and in that
game a 5 was played here we have Knight
to e7 so as you can see now this Knight
is supporting the push of the c5 pawn
this Knight is may be coming to g6 maybe
to g4 maybe to f5 we'll see how it goes
Lila goes for h4 preparing to expand
even further on on the King side we have
c5 black now as usual in the French has
this massive pawn pawn chain and still
has to decide how to develop the pieces
with h5 by legal ax h6 and now Knights
to h4 I useful move one of the rare
occasions where night and the rim is not
a grim or dim but the knight here
supports the g6 square but not not so
much needed as the pond does a great job
of that but it more importantly it
covers the f5 square also it makes room
for whites to push f4 and expand further
on the Kings side we have c4 Knight
comes to d2 and now b5 stockfish slowly
expands on the Queen side as there's
nothing going on on the King set for the
moment and the center is blocked we have
Queen g4 now comes a 5 by stockfish
grabbing even more space on the Queen
side Bishop to e2 and now a 4 even and
here a 3 so now even the Queen side is
completely blocked it's unlikely black
will ever get to put a beat before and
the white will it's unlikely that white
will ever get to push b3 the center is
pretty much closed so any possible pawn
break that might happen is either black
can go for f6 unlikely or white can go
f4 f5 so these are for the moment
possible breaks on the Kings side
Knight b8 as the position is now closed
stopped which is now Rima nuvaring we
have f4 by Lila
beat the c6 and now comes from Knights
to f1 this Knight wants to come to e3 to
support the DFS five square even further
we have Knights the a5 stock which now
has this very nice outpost on b3 for his
Knight and he will use it
we have Bishop to e3 making room for the
rook to move if the knight ever lands
and b3 which it does not b3 rook to d1
and now you have this position here
where well the entire position is pretty
much blocked stockfish grabbed all this
place on the Queen side he has a very
nice night on b3 that's okay you do have
a very nice nice and b3 but it's not
really doing all that much and on the
other hand you haven't really developed
any of your pieces nor are you sure were
to develop them for example if you try
something like night f5 to start
something then Bishop f2 simply getting
that Bishop out of the way and now black
will either capture which will only help
white attack the Queen Queen moves now
you can go Knight e3 this rook can come
to f1 you can push that five white is
getting too much out of this and if you
try something like 95 after Bishop f2
and Knight back to e7 to hope for some
sort of repetition then white will just
continue Knight f3 again further control
of DF v square and black will have to
figure out another plan so after this
rook to d1 we have King to d7 stockfish
now has a really cool plan he wants to
hide his King all the way on day 5 and
only then open up the King side we have
Bishop to f2 making room for the night
on III King to c7 and not 93 we have
King Tubby 7 Queen to h3 and now if you
try something like King to c7 or a slow
move then a white could start pushing g4
f5 and open up the position before black
is ready so black decides to take
matters in in his own own hands we have
g5 h captors and g6 on pasand
we have F captors on g6 and now g4 and
black continues with the plan you could
try something like g5 but it's not so
gonna do anything right boss here you
can capture Knight captures and again
black will be forced the for the rest of
the game to deal with to the e6 pawn
the backwards weak pawn but there's not
all that much black can do about it
so after G for King ea6 of rockfish
continues with the plan now we have
night h2g2 and it now comes rook the g8
we have burst of to f3 and now King to
a5 and now if you look at this King and
i-5 that is a very safe King I mean you
are not getting you're not getting
through to that King no way
Bishop to h4 pinning the night here also
taking further control of DF v square as
the knight will be unable to recapture
anything that is on f5 so g5 we have
Bishop 2g 3G captures now on f4 Bishop
captures would be not so great as night
the g6 could allow black to untangle a
bit so after G captures we have Knight
captures taking further control of the
g6 square sorry about that and also the
shortage for will be a threat once again
rook to a7 now after the knight moves
the rook can come help out with the
defense on the King side and we have
Bishop to h4 again pinning this night
here Bishop to d7 black develops the
light square bishop now the bishop can
also come to eh to help out with the
defense and here why the just castles
King side there is no problem with this
row being on the G file for the moment
h5 is not possible so Queen to a
starfish prepares h5 we have looked to
f2 and now h5 here of course you cannot
capture it as we already mentioned the
Jeep on a spin from the rock on g8
so after h5 will g5 grab a more space
and now Leila's plan is completely
different yes you do
release some of your control over the f5
square but now you have a great outpost
on f6 for any piece that might land on
it we have Knights to g6
Knight captures Queen captures and now
Bishop the g2 making room for this rook
to come to to f6
stock Fischer doesn't want the room to
come to f6 would an attack on the Queen
so first Queen to e8 we have looked to
f6 and now comes Bishop back to c8
making room for the other Brooke to come
help out with the defense Queen to g3
and now
look the c7 and here comes Bishop to h3
now white is starting to pile up against
this e six bone
we have Bishop to g7 and now even King
to H do not allele doesn't want after
this rook is captured by the bishop
that's the the king and the Queen are in
the same file so what do you do here
well obviously Bishop capture seems
interesting but after he captures White
has two connected passports and it will
be very hard to defend against this for
example the rook is already under attack
you have to move it or you have to
protect it
King f7 Queen f7 blocks the pawns and
also protects the rook rook g1 now
threatening g6 and now you can play rook
g6 okay now you have your look and your
queen stuck guarding the two passed
pawns Queen d6 you allow the White Queen
to infiltrate and it's it's a very
dangerous Queen that has a lot of
options so once black trades the Queen's
for example Queen d7 Queen captures the
bishop capture you can capture with the
rug because of Bishop captures any six
so after Bishop captures you would get
f7 and here black has just lost you have
to go something like rook c8 to defend
the queening square but now you get even
Knight captures on d5 with some with
some very nice ideas pawn captures
Bishop captures here rock to f8 blocking
but now even Bishop to e6 defending and
black is without a move here the king is
here keeping the night away from
entering the game but there's really no
other move you could try something like
that or you could try capturing the
bishop and then you simply get g6 and
it's all you can deliver a check or
something but there's there's no
stopping the to pass pawns
whatever you play King b6 then this is
coming captures and the Queen is into
the game so not something you want to do
capturing this rook rook to f7 was
played by stockfish and now we have
Knights the g2 just ignoring the attack
under Brooke and f6 this Knight is now
coming to f4 the queen is coming to e3
and the attack against the backwards
east exponent will be unstoppable
King to a6 finally making room for this
night to enter the game but now Queen to
e3
again if you capture the rook
it will not be any better because after
this pawn captures there will also be an
attack from the Queen towards the e6
pawn so we have King to a7 and now comes
Knight to f4 rook to e7 and now comes
Luke the g1 supporting the g5 point we
have King to b8 and now even g6 is
coming now taking away the Queen's
control of the h5 pawn so now even
capturing that point is a possibility
rook to h8 defending the pawn and now
comes Luke to g2 just improving the
position as the quote above the board
says never make a good move too soon
King back to a7 seeing what Leela has
prepared and now comes the Queen back to
f2 and here there's no really there's
really no good way to defend e6 pawn the
Queen f2 move is aimed at going for
Queen to f7 check once everything is
exchanged on e6 so just to give you an
idea of what legal our plant here if you
try something like ninety five to try
and get the knight into the game
then comes Bishop captures on e6 and
even though black is defending d6 square
more times than White is attacking it
the tactics work in white's favor Bishop
captures just simply Knight captures the
rook captures rook captures and Queen
captures and now black is up a piece but
it's a it's a knight on a five so Queen
to f7 check and now you either have to
move and lose the Queen or you have to
trade Queens Queen captures G captures
now again you create two connected
passed pawns and you don't have time to
act as your bishop on g6 is under attack
you have to move the bishop Bishop h6
but now comes six and finally you do get
to activate your knight but it's far too
late
rook g8 and okay you don't have to
capture you have you you do have the
option of moving at the bishop is
controlling a fade but simply Bishop g5
either forcing black to capture and then
you get a queen or black has to move
Bishop g7 and now you even get a 7 now
black has to give up a knight Knight
captures Bishop captures and again you
will win a piece once this pawn reaches
here for example Bishop h6 now you can
go Bishop c5 check oh it's taking a6 you
can even go rook b8 and now you force
black the capture II either that or
you're you're winning a piece but after
black character
now you create a windmill you force the
king either to go to a five and then the
king will be checkmated for example if
King to a 5 then rook captures on a six
and now whatever you do let's say you go
look if you check King moves rue goes
back you have to give up but at one
point you are getting checkmated so
that's not really no nothing you can do
here or after rugby six check you will
go here and then you just lose the rook
rook f6 check King be a rogue captures
and you are down a rook and losing the
game
so after this Queen to have to move you
don't really have a way of stopping
bunch of characters on e6 so doctors
finds a different way to defend we have
looked the b7 now just giving up the
point straight up but with with a
different idea Bishop captures on e6 we
have Bishop captures sorry not to that
but Bishop captures I'm on f6 first we
have Bishop captures on f6 now Bishop
captures on e6 and now Bishop captures
on h8 and now stalks which doesn't
recapture because of Knight captures on
e6 first night the g8 and now Bishop
returns to f6 so stockfish is still
alive but still due to past bones it's
not going to be easy
Knight c1 stock which tries to finally
activate this night but now Queen III
attacking the knight force the stock
wish to either go back stay passive or
go night to d3 which doctor does we have
Knight captures pawn captures and Queen
captures losing yet another pawn and
rook to b8 we have King to g3
now Leo just starts improving the
position there should be six King to h4
kicked the b7 and now even g7
a division for now is controlling the g8
squares so it's not that big of a deal
Queen to d7 and now rook to g5 we have
looked the c8 and now look back to g1
Bishop to f7 and now Queen to f3
we have Queen - eh and now comes Luke to
f1 preparing to move the bishop and well
there will be some discoveries here so
look to c7 bringing a further control
towards the the f7 square Queen to d3
now just trying to get black into
sort of a tooth swung which black can't
really avoid with with much success
brush up the g8 and now King to g5 and
now there's really not all that much you
can play you can't really move the rook
if you go Ruby 7 you know the Queen no
longer controls the b5 point if you
can't go here you can go f7 I figure
King abrooke f7 then well the Queen is
no longer protecting the h5 point but
the real threat is queen g6 now
completely pinning black and there's
there would be nothing black could play
here or you could try something like
king b6 just moving the King but again
Queen g6 forces a queen trade and also
threatens discoveries so not not all
that many moves you could do here you
can't really nothing nothing for you to
do you can't move the Queen the Queen
has to keep an eye on the b5 point so
black tries a different active Plan B 4
and ok a capture some before and not
roof to c4 hoping the block of the
position at least now the Queen will not
be able to land on b5 so now the white
the black Queen can move King to h6 now
we have Queen to e6 and now Queen to f5
offering the Queen trade of course black
cannot offer a black cannot accept the
Queen trade as he's down material we
have Queen back to 8 and now we have
rook to f3 rook to c6 and now finally
Queen captures on h5 grabbing that pawn
bishop to f7 Queen back to f5 and now
Bishop to e6 going to g6 offering a
queen trade Bishop to f7 stalkerish
repeats the position a few times and now
Queen to d3 again threatening Queen B 5
checks so we have looked the ECX to the
Queen again has the keeper and the be 5
square King g5 and now Queen to c6 and
here we have rook to g3 rook to e8 and
now rook to h3 the rook is now
threatening to come to a sheet will
Brooke the g8 and now rope to h8 it
would be possible here but for some
reason lila first goes from rook to h4
we have Queen d7 King back to f4 we have
Bishop to e6 and now look to h7 we have
King to b6 and here we have look to h6
and after King to b7
it was in this position that stockfish
resigned the game IRA it's been putting
it out to me that it's not like in the
match alpha 0 versus dogfish that if too
much time passed before either side made
a moved and it was considered
resignation here if both engines agree
yeah one of the winning conditions is if
both in Leela and stalkerish agree that
the advantage the other side has is
above 70 point then it is considered a
resignation
so after King b7 we do have a
resignation why why black resigns well
he is down four pawns that's one and on
the other hand after Queen to g6 there's
really not all that much you can do you
can try Bishop f7 but then comes Queen
g2 this would be the idea now after this
Bishop moves you can see that the rook
is controlling this entire 6th rank and
also c4 is a threat as the queen is on
the same diagonal as the King so you
could try King b6 moving the King but
then Bishop the d8 check and you can see
that now it's a double check from the
bishop and the rook why white will be
breaking through on the other hand after
something like Bishop 3 6 you will push
c4 and that you will break through King
a7 you can push c5 after Queen b7 you
can push even b5 here black doesn't
really have much options here Queen will
capture and now brush up to d8 will
break through you are you open up the
attack from the rook to the bishop after
Queen e8 you are finally getting in
Queen g6 and now after Queen captures
rook captures Bishop f7 you are gonna go
there should be six check King j6 and
now King to f5 you don't you no longer
care about your rook this will capture
screen captures now next move you will
play King f7 and you will get a pawn a
queen here you will capture black's rook
let's say you go black place something
not really all that much black can play
you go here rook moves you bring your
Queen into the game black and capture
you can capture and now now it's a
completely winning position there is no
move black can't even play you can go
for this pawn but then all of the pawns
are promoting it and it's game over
but yeah stockfish I wanted to have
nothing to do with this after King to b7
it was
the game was over and moved 77 or sorry
76 yeah that's the game from the TCC
super finals
I believe that Lila won and like I said
the first thing in the description below
will be the link where you can follow
this match live I forgot to mention the
match is being played in classical time
control so it's really gonna take a long
time to finish this match but we will
get some very interesting games as a now
stockfish had to play this version of
different defense then Lila has to play
this exact version of the French defense
and stocks which can push for a win with
the white pieces and so they will go
through every opening and we will get
very exciting games that we would often
not see perhaps it would be better for
Lila if they played without any opening
theory as that's how Lila trained same
as alpha zero but maybe the games
wouldn't be this interesting as this way
one side always has an advantage from
the beginning and then it's interesting
to see how the other side will defend
and how the side that has the advantage
will will push for the win and also you
might get ideas as if you will face
these openings yourselves you can get
some ideas on how to break through yeah
do check out the live event also some
other very interesting links in the
description below like a link to a
little hs0 blog well they will often
inform you about everything that
happened so feel free to follow that as
well I would like to thank Marcia London
Jonathan Tolan solid systems David
Tenorio and Oscar Cabrera for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos ER think all for watching and I
will see you soon
most likely with the Oscar versus
Capablanca the negotiations thank you
all and I'll see you soon